Fasting is a Muslimonly prerogative. Is
that correct? That's right. It is
compulsory only for a Muslim to fast. It
is not a requirement for a non-Muslim or
unbeliever to fast. And the reason is
that Allah says in the Quran, Allah says
in surah nur chapter number 24 verse
number 39 that the deeds of a
non-believer a person who is a
non-Muslim the deeds of an unbeliever is
like a mirage in a desert and the
thirsty person thinks that there is
water but when he reaches there he does
not find anything else but he finds
Allah and Allah will pay him for his
deeds and Allah is swift in taking of
accounts. That means in the hereafter
the unbeliever for his deeds he will get
nothing and Allah is swift in taking of
accounts. So for unbeliever all the
deeds they are useless in the hereafter
because all the deeds have to be
accompanied with the intention and as we
discussed
yesterday that one of the criteria an
important criterion for a person's fast
to be accepted is the nia. It is
intention and the intention is that the
fast should only be for Allah subhanana
wa tala and no one else. So if a
non-Muslim if unbeliever who does not
believe in Allah subhanana wa tala where
is the question of him doing the nia
doing the intention of fasting for Allah
subhanaa tala. So that's the reason it
is not required for unbeliever to fast.
If he fast without the intention it will
just be like anything else. It will not
be an act of worship. It not be a fast
as is considered in Islam. So therefore
the nia the intention is very important.
So for unbeliever any act of worship
until he has faith until he believes
until he believes that there is only one
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala unless he says
the
Muhammad Allah that there's no god but
Allah and prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him is the messenger of Allah all the
acts of worship they're useless for the
hereafter but the moment a non-believer
a person who's not a Muslim he accepts
Islam for him it becomes obligatory he
fakes accepts Islam in the middle of the
month of Ramadan. From that moment
onwards, fasting becomes compulsory for
him. But the past Allah will not take
into account. Allah says in the Quran,
Allah says in surah Anfal chapter number
8 verse number 38 that say to the
unbelievers that if they start believing
the past will be forgiven. That means
the moment a non-Muslim accepts Islam
all his past sins will be forgiven. But
the moment he accepts Islam from that
time it becomes obligated on him to
fast.